KENDRA COMMANDER: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to Authors At.
My name is Kendra Commander.
I am on the partnerships team
at google.org, focusing on
access in the developing
world.
We have a very exciting
talk today.
We have author, filmmaker,
entrepreneur, professional
climber, Majka Burhardt joining
us today to talk about
coffee, education,
sustainability in Ethiopia.
And I think you guys
are in for a
really, really big treat.
It's a sort of combination of
multimedia presentation as
well as talk.
There will be some distortion
perhaps in the
quality of the video.
So please, it's not her fault.
It's our fault.
So welcome to the talk.
And hope that you
guys enjoy it.
[APPLAUSE]
MAJKA BURHARDT: Thanks,
Kendra.
Let's get started.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PANTING]
MAJKA BURHARDT: We have
some video going on.
[PANTING]
-Watch me.
-All right, got it.
[PANTING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MAJKA BURHARDT: All right,
how are you feeling?
Anyone feeling a
little anxious?
A little scared?
Wondering if I ever
catch my breath?
Anyone want to go climbing?
All right.
[LAUGHING]
MAJKA BURHARDT: So let's take
that edge with us for the next
30 minutes.
So I'm going to start off.
Anyone in this group
Ethiopian?
OK, zero hands are going
up right now.
So I'm going to give
you guys a hint.
I'm going to ask you guys
that question again at
the end of this talk.
Before I do, I'm going to tell
you three stories that I can
guarantee are going to change
your perspective on Ethiopia,
adventure, coffee,
development, and
our role in the world.
I do speak this fast.
We have a lot to talk about.
So we're going to get
right after it.
First, let me introduce you to
Marsha Aday, his wife, Gete
Tebo, and six of their
seven children.
Marsha Aday is the tribal leader
of the Messa tribe and
lives on the flanks of Mount
Yero Wallo deep in the Amaro
Mountains of Ethiopia.
I wasn't looking for Marsha
Aday exactly.
I was looking for the
best storyteller.
I traveled for six hours that
day by car and by foot and for
two days previous to that
from Addis Ababa,
the capital of Ethiopia.
And when I got to Mount Yero
Wallo, I walked through--
it's basically the Switzerland
of Ethiopia.
You're walking through
shocks of Kelly green
false banana trees.
The coffee trees, the wild
coffee trees, are growing with
such ferocity they seem to
sprout new leaves and coffee
cherries by the second.
When I got there, I asked
everyone and I said, who's the
best storyteller here?
And without long, I knew that I
was looking for Marsha Aday.
Marsha Aday lives in a
home without a door.
That signifies his status as
the head of the tribe.
He's protected by everyone
around him.
And he can also have full
vantage point of the
valley below him.
So he knew I was coming to talk
to him a full hour before
I even knew who he was
or where I was going.
He was getting ready.
He was taking all of the
furniture out of his home and
putting it outside, covering it
with skins and with furs to
make sure that we'd
be comfortable.
And when I finally arrived, we
sat down and started talking
about coffee.
Marsha Aday is a coffee farmer
in one of the most rural parts
of Ethiopia, which means he
makes less than $1 a day.
However, he drinks a fortune
every day in coffee.
Coffee is so plentiful here in
Ethiopia that people have
coffee trees in their
backyard.
They have coffee forests
in their backyard.
And they drink coffee so much
that if Marsha Aday's personal
coffee grove was getting top
value in the market, which is
about $150, $160 a pound, he
himself would drink $75 a day
in coffee, which is a four month
income to him that he's
just drinking away
in his coffee.
So is he a poor Ethiopian
coffee farmer?
Or is he a rich Ethiopian
Totally depends on how we're
willing to look at Ethiopia,
coffee, economics, any of it.
Coffee in the Amaro Mountains
didn't come here from people.
But it came here from nature.
Wef Zerash is the term for
natural seed dispersal by
birds and by animals
in Ethiopia.
And the coffee, as I said, is
so plentiful in this part of
Ethiopia that Marsha Aday likes
to say that there's no
way for the cherries
to leave the trees.
His coffee is accounted for in
legend in Ethiopia in the 10th
century BC.
But Marsha Aday's ancestors
didn't start drinking it until
3,000 years later in
the 20th century.
And the story is told that they
were convinced that these
bright red coffee cherries, if
you would eat one of those,
you would be burned.
Because whatever was in it was
clearly going to explode in
your mouth.
And it wasn't until the mid
1900s where actually traders
came into the Amaro Mountains.
They came on camels from the low
lands of Kerdea on camels
to the highlands of
the Amaro and
started trading for coffee.
And Marsha Aday's ancestors
were like, hmm.
What's going on here?
We thought these were
going to burn you.
And they waited until the same
traders returned, unburned,
before they started actually
consuming that coffee.
And once they did, it
was off the hook.
This coffee consumption is
like anywhere in Ethiopia
three times a day, four times a
day multiple cups of coffee.
That's part of the every
day culture there.
Marsha Aday told me this story
while holding a bright red
coffee cherry in his hand
and handing it to me.
And I bit into it.
And when you bite into a ripe
one, your teeth kind of pierce
the outer skin.
And I thought, what if this
could be the best
coffee in the world?
What if this is the coffee that
could also get that kind
of value on the market?
What would that mean for
these people here?
Marsha Aday lives a half a
drive away from any town,
assuming you can actually
drive on the roads.
The roads are more often used
as flat spots for drying
coffee than they are for any
sort of transportation.
When you're actually driving
there, you have to stop and
let people move some of the
coffee away off the road.
Because it's so unlikely to
have a vehicle show up.
I was there for four days.
It was the only vehicle
we had.
We almost didn't get out.
Because a huge flash flood
came in and made
everything a mud slide.
So we could have been there for
quite a bit longer before
another vehicle would've
been able to come up.
As I said, the coffee topples
over itself as it stretches up
the flanks of Mount
Yero Wallo.
Marsha Aday and I were speaking
for about a half an
hour at this point.
And he was so excited.
Because no one had ever asked
him about his coffee.
And to the best of his
knowledge, no one had ever
asked his ancestors.
But he was sure, without a
doubt, that his coffee was the
best in Ethiopia.
And I've actually never met
anyone who thought differently
about their coffee, right?
And we were speaking.
And he kept telling
me, my coffee
is the best in Ethiopia.
And by the time he'd said it
three times, he was saying it
to me in English.
Because the translation had
computed at that point.
And at that point, I said, well,
we're going to have to
have some coffee.
We're going to have to really
celebrate this.
And he said, yes.
But first, we should
kill an ox.
Because that's a logical
thing to do when
you're pretty excited.
And you're in Ethiopia.
And you're thinking, we should
have a celebration.
But it's the afternoon.
And these clouds are mounting.
And actually grabbing the ox,
killing the ox, slaughtering
it, cooking it, this
can take some time.
We were a little bit pressed.
So we decided that the
alternative was that Marsha
Aday was going to
dance for me.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SINGING IN A FOREIGN
LANGUAGE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MAJKA BURHARDT: This is his
costume for being the leader
of the Messa tribe that goes
back seven generations.
And this his is pre-coffee
dance.
He was really excited.
So post-coffee, we're going
to amp it up a little bit.
And we went into his home to
find out what post-coffee was
going to be.
And we walked inside.
And Gete Tebo was already
preparing coffee.
So she had raw coffee beans.
They were over a charcoal
fire on a flat pan.
She's roasting them.
All a sudden, that sweet smell
is infusing this earthen home.
My stomach's growling.
The clouds are building
in the east.
And then she takes
those perfectly
roasted coffee beans.
She puts them in a mortar and
pestle, takes her 30 seconds.
I've been working in Ethiopia
for 10 years.
It takes me still about 35
minutes to do what it took her
30 seconds to do to grind
those things by hand.
Pours them into a thick-bellied
and thin-necked
jabana, a clay pot.
Puts it on the stove.
And the smells just keep
infusing, sweet
and citrus and honey.
And I keep thinking, God,
this is going to be
the best coffee ever.
And then this huge
clap of thunder
comes in and lightning.
And everything goes
dark in the home.
And I take one last breath.
And I run as fast as I can
to escape a flash flood.
And I never had that coffee.
70% of Ethiopia lies
between 2,000 and
8,000 feet in elevation.
50% of Ethiopia is incredibly
vegetated, moist, dark
volcanic soil.
It's the perfect place
for growing coffee.
The images we're used to seeing
of Ethiopia, dry,
barren desert.
That's only a third
of Ethiopia.
This is the land where
humanity began.
And if you listen to legend,
coffee showed up right after
humans and in fact in
the sixth century.
Ethiopia has 10,000 different
types of coffee, 10,000 unique
flavors, varietals.
And at this point, the
estimation is that only half
of them have actually been
found, tasted, and cataloged.
So 5,000 different types of
coffees are still lying in
wait in the forest
in Ethiopia.
That's incredibly intoxicating
for any sort of coffee
aficionado, entrepreneur to say,
what does it mean that
this country, one of the poorest
countries in the
world, has the greatest supply
of one of the globe's richest
commodities?
What can we do to kind of
push that together?
What can we do to take those
tastes out of the forest?
Ethiopia, over 60%
of its foreign
earnings come from coffee.
If you gave every coffee farmer
in Ethiopia 10 cents
more, Ethiopia's annual income
from coffee would go by $60
million a year.
But I don't think that's
a really good idea.
Because Ethiopia is also kind
of this bastion, has been a
bastion of aid.
It's been the largest
recipient of aid in
sub-Saharan Africa
since the '80s.
It's been the place where great
failures of aid have
happened and great successes
of current sustainable
development.
And if we go in from a coffee
perspective and just say,
let's pay more to Ethiopia
because it's Ethiopian coffee.
And we bet it's good.
We're going to be doing the
same thing by going in
with a blind eye.
And I think what will be more
interesting and what's
starting to happen is to go into
a nuanced conversation
about nuanced coffee.
So here we are in California.
You all have probably been in
restaurants or in cafes when
you walk in, you actually get
a bit of a coffee menu.
And you know that there
are different tastes.
There are different flavor
profiles for coffee.
Imagine if you went to the best
restaurant in Palo Alto.
And the coffee list was as
big as the wine list.
That's the potential we're
talking about.
And if we do that, then suddenly
you're rewarding
quality and taste.
And you're actually entering
a complicated conversation,
which is where things, in my
opinion, start to get a lot
more interesting.
This is what we're used to
seeing about Ethiopia,
drought, famine, poverty.
It's a constant and consumate
negative trifecta.
I think coffee can actually
change this.
And I think it can do it because
I'm kind of addicted
to complexity.
And I think that this
is probably a crew--
people at Google are thinking.
People are striving.
And it's like, instead of going
towards a simple life,
how can we go towards a complex
life in the way that
we interact with the world?
For me, it started simply
with a free latte.
We're going to go back
in time here.
So it's 2007.
And I was going to my
neighborhood coffee shop.
And there's this creepy guy
outside whispering to me,
which I'm not sure
about you all.
But whispering in public
to strangers, not cool.
It's just not the way
you make friends.
But then I'm walking into
this coffee shop.
And this guy's like, hey, free
latte across the street.
It's like, yeah, OK.
That's great.
You're weird.
Just kind of move away.
I'm going to go into
the coffee shop.
No, free lattes.
I said, but I don't
drink lattes.
He said, but they're free.
It's like, that's a
pretty good point.
And then I look across
the street.
And this kind of smoking
handsome man was serving up
the free coffee.
So I was like, all right,
the free latte is
looking really good.
So I cruise across the street.
And I'm lactose intolerant.
So this is already not a good
idea to be doing this.
But I go up there.
And I get a free latte.
And I sit down.
I start eavesdropping
on the conversation.
It's a coffee company
called Novo.
They're in the Front
Range of Colorado.
And they start talking about a
coffee called geisha that was
at that time getting $150
a pound on the market.
That's grown in Panama.
And they were going on a trip
to try to find the genetic
roots of it in Ethiopia.
It took me about 30 seconds.
I stood up.
I introduced myself.
I'm like, do you guys
need a journalist?
Three months later,
I'm in Ethiopia.
When I got to Ethiopia, I
understood about 0.003% of the
coffee world.
I was a writer.
I was an educated coffee
consumer to
the best of my ability.
And I went into Ethiopia
being like, local,
organic, fair trade.
Those are what matters.
And suddenly, I'm in Ethiopia.
And I'm like, whoa, I have no
idea what the heck I'm doing.
This is completely
overwhelming.
And frankly, it was really
scary for me.
And so what I did is I turned to
a part of Ethiopia that was
way more comfortable for me.
And that's because in my other
life, I'm a professional
climber, which I just got out of
the Wyoming wilderness and
the winds where I was climbing
for seven days.
And we were laughing.
Because I'm covered in scratches
and scrapes because
of shoving my hands into
granite cracks.
So when I was in Ethiopia and I
was scared about coffee and
I saw a picture of these towers
in northern Ethiopia, I
was like, yeah, that's
my home in Ethiopia.
I'm going to go climbing
in Ethiopia.
An Ethiopian publisher caught
wind of this plan.
And they came to me with
a plan of their own.
And they're like, this
is super cool.
You're going to go climbing.
You're a writer.
Why don't you write a book about
climbing in Ethiopia?
I was like, yeah, that
sounds great.
And they said, and by writing
a book about climbing in
Ethiopia, you're going
to save Ethiopia.
So check it.
You're a climber.
You're a writer.
And someone tells you, if you
write a book about doing what
you love, you're going to save
one of the poorest countries
in the world.
That's a pretty good deal.
That feels pretty good.
So I was on board.
And the plan was that if I wrote
this book, that millions
of climbers would then
flock to Ethiopia.
And they'd change the economics
of Ethiopia.
So a little show of hands, who
in the room is a climber?
OK, cool.
And everybody else basically
knows what climbing is.
How many of you have flocked
to Ethiopia since my first
book came out?
Awesome.
Everybody in the room raise
their hand just
for point of reference.
So it was hard to pass up.
You think this could be
a really good idea.
And we got there.
And we showed up the
Gheralta massif--
this is in northern Ethiopia.
It's never been climbed.
We thought, we are so smart.
Look, it-- we're so proud
of ourselves.
It was myself and a team
of four other women.
And my friend Gabe Rogel was
shooting photos for the book.
And we're like, no
one's been here.
God, well how silly everybody
else is, how smart we are that
we figured this out,
that we're the
ones discovering this.
And we're in this landscape
in northern Ethiopia.
This is the site of the
famine in the '80s.
This is the place that was
hardest hit where millions
starved, millions died.
They were affected by political
power plays, food shortages.
This is the heart of it
in northern Ethiopia.
And here we are climbing
there.
This is actually what pretty
much created aid as we all
know it in this room.
Because in '84, you had this
really neat confluence where
you had the fact that crisis
could be delivered direct to
our television sets at home.
You had a very affluent US,
Canada, Western Europe ready
to help, ready to save things.
And you had this dismal country
entrenched in famine.
And how could we not react?
Most of us in this room have
probably been affected by that
part in 1984.
I was 8 during the famine
in Ethiopia.
I was in Minneapolis
where I grew up.
I went to Montessori school,
which is relevant.
Because when Michael Jackson,
Cyndi Lauper, Waylon Jennings,
when they all got together and
did "We are the World," at
Montessori school, you sing
it like twice a day.
It would be like school
assembly.
And we'd be singing it.
And then it would be
in the afternoon.
And you'd be singing it again.
And I was so inspired by Michael
Jackson that I was
like, I should write
a song of my own.
If Michael Jackson writes about
Ethiopia, I'm going to
write about Ethiopia.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-(SINGING) I want to help
a kid in Ethiopia.
Nobody else can help this one.
MAJKA BURHARDT: He we go.
-Everybody needs somebody.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
MAJKA BURHARDT: See?
There's three and a half
more minutes of that.
I'm sure you all wish
you could hear it.
I will make it available, pop it
up on my drive later on so
you all can download it and
listen to it or torture
yourselves with it,
depending on what
you're thinking of doing.
23 years later after I wrote
that song, I was
doing this in Ethiopia.
And as I said, we thought we
were the smartest people in
the world that we'd
figured this out.
And it went incredibly well, to
climb, to put first ascents
up on sandstone towers where
you're shoving your hands and
your feet into cracks.
And they're getting purchase.
And you're putting your
equipment and your metal gear.
And you're clipping
your rope in.
And you're pretty sure
it's going to keep
you safe if you fall.
And it went great
for like a day.
And then it went
horribly wrong.
So here's the difference.
It's going great on the left.
It's a really cool photo.
On the right, it's a
really bad photo.
This is sort of the difference
in what happened.
Because there was professional
photographer Gabe taking
photos when we were happy.
And there was Mike is very
scared and doesn't want to die
in Ethiopia on the right
side of the screen.
Because what happened is this
crack that we were following--
we were trying to climb
this 500 foot tower.
The crack disappeared.
And suddenly, we just had
the face to climb.
And the rock that we were
climbing there was the kind of
rock that if you went up, you
could snap off the face hold
with your finger, with
your pinkie.
You felt like if you just stared
at it for too long, it
would return back to its
natural sand state.
And that was all we had to go
on when this crack ended.
And it was a point for me in my
climbing career that I was
like, wow, I don't even know
if I want to do this.
But I'm writing a book about
climbing in Ethiopia.
And if I can't get beyond here,
what kind of book is
this going to be?
And I ended up doing it.
And we got to the top
of this climb.
And when we got to the top of
it, I was like, OK, now what?
How are we going to get down?
And I'm probably going to
have to do this again.
Because last I checked, it
wasn't a children's book that
I signed a book deal for.
So I'm probably going to have
to climb more than one of
these things.
And I'm scared about how
I'm going to do it.
This was the safe and
known route for me.
Coffee was supposed to
be overwhelming.
Climbing was supposed to be
what would be easy for me.
And yet, when we got down from
climbing this tower--
we did our first ascent
on that--
we started hanging out with
a family at the base.
And this is a 14--
excuse me, a 13-year-old girl
with her 4-month-old daughter
on her back.
So here I am thinking about
exploring a country through
climbing, through opportunity,
through adventure.
And then at the other side,
I'm looking at one of the
highest needs for maternal
health care in the world.
How do you put those
things together?
And how was I going to
put those things
together in the book?
And the only way that I figured
out how to do it was
to get comfortable with what I
now think about as the middle
place, where some things
make sense.
And some things never do.
Where that climbing and that
need for maternal health care
can go together.
Back in 2007, I never thought
I would go back to Ethiopia.
I thought, I went there.
I had a really good time.
I spent four months.
I wrote a book.
But then I went on a speaking
tour for 50 cities when my
first book "Vertical
Ethiopia" came out.
And I tried to tell these really
big complex stories
about Ethiopia from
that middle place.
And what I saw is that people
wanted to know more.
And they would come up
to me afterwards.
And they would be like, hey,
so about that coffee?
What's the deal with that?
Whatever happened to that?
Have you ever gone back and
thought more about that?
And pretty soon, I saw that
two things were going on.
Number one, people really
like coffee.
That's kind of obvious.
But it became very clear
to me at that point.
And number two, we're sort of
obsessed with Ethiopia.
And part of that-- it's like if
I had written my first book
about the Ivory Coast, it
probably wouldn't have been on
a 50 city speaking tour.
But we've all been trained to
pay attention to Ethiopia from
global media, in part because of
what happened in the '80s,
in part because it just became
this relative point for us to
all cast off of in its aid
center of gravity, but also
because of the ancient Aksumite
empire, Haile Selassie.
It's the only country in Africa
that was never colonized.
It has this rich history.
We've just been taught to
pay attention to it.
And I started thinking about,
well, how can I leverage that
for Ethiopia?
What's going to be the most
interesting and enticing way
that I can do it?
And I went back.
And I was back in the States.
And this is not Ethiopia.
This is New Hampshire, which is
where I went that winter to
go ice climbing, in 2008.
And while I was there, I was
like, I'm going to go back.
What's my plan?
And I decided that I would go
back and write a book about
coffee and culture and
connecting those two things to
try to tell a broader story
about Ethiopia.
And then something
else happened.
I got a phone call.
This is Imagine 1 Day.
Imagine 1 Day is a Canadian
nonprofit that is basically a
leadership development
powerhouse in Ethiopia veiled
as an education nonprofit.
And Image 1 Day had this idea
that they were going to go
into Ethiopia and support
primary school education.
And that's how they
started out.
But last year, they were working
in Bale, which is in
south central Ethiopia.
And they working with
their teachers.
And they're working
on what they're
going to teach in schools.
But they're also doing this
whole life skills training.
So they're talking to them about
communication skills,
about goal setting.
And these teachers flooded the
Bale chapter of the Commercial
Bank of Ethiopia and opened bank
accounts the day after
this life skills training
happened so much so that the
Commercial Bank of Ethiopia
called Imagine 1 Day and was
like, um, who are you?
What are you doing?
We've never had teachers open
savings account like
this in this area.
Imagine 1 Day, up in the north
of Ethiopia, they have this
great scholarship program
for high school kids.
They wanted to work in
primary education.
Now they're giving scholarships
to high school kids.
And they're doing it where
they're like, you, you're
super motivated.
So I'm going to give
you a loan.
Because in Ethiopia, to go to
high school, it's basically
like going to boarding school.
Because you're going
to have to travel.
You're not going to have it
in your remote village.
So in order for you to have
the money to go to school,
we're going to give
you seed money.
Get your supplies.
And we're going to give your
parents a loan to buy a really
skinny cow.
And then your parents are
going to feed that cow.
And they're going
to have a whole
animal fattening program.
They're going to sell
that fat cow.
They're going to save
some money.
They're going to buy some
more skinny cows.
And at the end of four years,
these parents are going to
have actually financed three
years of that kid's high
school education.
And the one year that
Imagine 1 Day did
is going to be forgiven.
This is a program that this
was never their intention.
This was completely outside
of their wheelhouse.
What the heck is a nonprofit
focused in education doing
fattening 177 cows and opening
497 bank accounts and working
with schools and going to some
of the poorest people in the
world and saying, you
want a school?
That's great.
Help us pay for it.
Asking the poorest people
in the world to
actually spend money.
And that's part of what Imagine
1 Day does is they're
like, what do you want?
Can you help us get there?
And what they've seen is a
resounding yes from these
communities in Ethiopia.
Like, we want to help.
You have communities who go
and petition the cement
companies nearby and say,
we really need a road.
And those communities
created that road.
It wasn't Imagine 1
Day who did that.
It was the community.
And there are examples of this
happening throughout Ethiopia
with these non-profits.
And part of it is because you
have this confluence.
So many people flooded
to Ethiopia in the
'80s and the '90s.
And so many people were doing a
very large and messy version
of aid that it was bound to
happen that people were going
to start getting streamlined
and working towards
sustainable development.
When Imagine 1 Day gave me a
call in 2008, we were like, we
need to work together.
Because what we're both trying
to do is somehow change the
conversation about Ethiopia.
And we're here in the US.
There's a pretty international
crowd in this room and the
people that I've talked
to already.
We all know what national
identity is on a global scale,
that countries are
misrepresented and
misunderstood constantly in
our world and truncated to
become smaller and
easier to digest.
And we thought, if we can help
change the conversation about
Ethiopia, where are those
conversation shifts going to
be more important on the global
scale down the road?
I've since worked with
Imagine 1 Day.
We've combined rock climbing,
education, coffee, eye care,
all of these different ways
to keep blowing it out.
And a lot of non-profits
will approach me.
And they're like, we want
to work with you.
And one of the first questions
I say is, are you willing to
go outside your wheelhouse?
Because non-profits have had a
focus for a long time about
saying, this is the one
thing I'm going to do.
I'm going to make sure that
I'm focused on foot care.
Because foot care is the
way that people are
going to move around.
And it's going--
whatever my mandate is.
But if there isn't
collaboration, if people
aren't saying, in order to do
this, then I need to work with
the schools, and I'm
going to work with
the health care systems.
Then these things die.
And these things die a really
long death that gives aid the
bad name that it kind of had.
And it's really fascinating to
me that if you take a country,
like Ethiopia, that was once,
like I said, that largest
recipient of aid in sub-Saharan
Africa, what if we
could kick total butt on
sustainable development and be
the leader for that?
Wouldn't that be one of the
greatest things to come out of
what's happened in Ethiopia
in the past 30 years?
It's not super easy.
And one thing that I will
definitely admit is Ethiopia
is not a perfect country.
I mean, no one in this room
can come up with a country
that's perfect.
But that's sort of the point.
And I like to think Ethiopian
is like the ultimate
doppelganger for all
of us in the world.
And if it can succeed, then
we can succeed at this
complexity.
And for me, that all comes
back to coffee.
And the reason it does is
because in Ethiopia, you have
80 languages, 200 dialects,
10,000 types of coffee.
Multiply that all, do some extra
numeric, get to infinite
numbers of stories about
coffee and complexity.
And in Ethiopia, when you
drink coffee, you
drink it as a ritual.
You drink it as a way to
celebrate your culture.
And the stories that
there are abound.
This is a guy named Gebru who
lives up in northern Ethiopia.
And he told me that when he was
growing up, he was told if
he drank coffee, he wouldn't
make it to paradise or heaven.
And the proof from his parents
came in the following story.
That when Jesus was
killed, coffee
didn't mourn Jesus properly.
So when Jesus was killed, the
Earth went into mourning.
So the rivers were dry.
The trees were completely
barren.
The wind was still.
But the only plant that kept
growing was the coffee plant.
It sprouted new leaves.
It had fresh cherries.
Coffee, as Gebru says,
didn't cry for Jesus.
So he wasn't allowed to drink
it when he was growing up.
He told me this story over a cup
of coffee in his mid '40s.
So clearly, we've moved
on from this.
He thinks he still has a decent
shot at paradise.
But most of the kids in his
generation didn't drink coffee
growing up but then kind of
moved on to having it when
they got older.
A couple hours south of where
Gebru is in northern Ethiopia,
on the shores of Lake Tana,
there's a place called the
Zegay Peninsula where in 1307
Bishop Abuna Mariam gathered
his flock of people.
And they settled there.
And they said, what are
we going to do?
How are we going to survive?
And he said, don't
worry about it.
And he took his prayer stick.
And he broke it across
his leg.
And he planted one piece
in the ground.
And he broke it again and
planted two more pieces.
And he said, come
back tomorrow.
So everybody came back
the next day.
And there were three
crops growing,
coffee, hops, and lemon.
And the bishop made his people
promise that those were the
only crops that they
would ever have
on the Zegay Peninsula.
And to this day-- this
was in 1307.
To this day, those are
the only crops grown
on the Zegay Peninsula.
And they're transported across
Lake Tana on these papyrus
boats every day.
Coffee origin stories
abound in Ethiopia.
Like I said, we have the
multiplier, right?
A friend of mine once said
that if you flew over
Ethiopia, and you had a lot of
gentle darts, just like little
stickies or something
like that that
had a little traction.
And you just dropped them.
Every place they landed, you'd
have a new story about coffee
in Ethiopia.
And that's probably true.
Have any of you guys heard
of the story of Khaldi?
So Khaldi, there's a very famous
story that if coffee
comes from Ethiopia, there
was a guy named Khaldi.
He's Christian.
He's Muslim.
He's a delinquent.
He's a scholar.
There's lots of different
variations.
The bottom line is, Khaldi
saw some goats having
a really good time.
And he's like, that looks fun.
And he went and was like,
wow, they're having fun.
Because there were
eating coffee.
So he started eating coffee,
brewing coffee.
Boom, coffee.
Khaldi, most stories,
is from Kaffa.
Kaffa is a region, the kind
of kingdom of Kaffa in the
central Ethiopia.
And it's a great onomatopoeic
link to say Kaffa, coffee,
which is not actually true.
It's a really cool story.
But coffee, the word, comes from
the Arabic word Qahwa,
which is a drink made
from the brew.
There's a great story about
the seventh century coffee
being discovered by Prophet
Muhammad's grandsons.
His mother was giving
them a bath.
And she tossed their bath
water out the window.
And the next morning, a coffee
forest had sprung up there.
And that began the Muslim
ritual, in Ethiopia, of using
coffee beans for ceremonial
purposes.
There's a story about a ox
that smelled really good.
And he started coffee.
Because he smelled good.
And people wanted to smell
as good as the ox.
There's no right story.
And that's part of the beauty
of the way stories are
expressed in Ethiopia.
And when you have coffee,
that's your
time to share that.
Coffee is usually drunk in a
three step ritual called a
coffee ceremony.
So when I was with Marsha Aday,
the coffee I didn't get
to drink, Gete Tebo, his wife,
was making the first cup of
coffee, super, super
strong coffee.
And once we all had that, she'd
pour water into that
same pot and re-brew it.
And then we'd have a second
weaker cup and then a third
weaker cup.
And in the Amaro Mountains, if
you show up in the first cup
of coffee, and there's an
unmarried woman who's in that
house and you cross the
threshold during the first
cup, she's yours.
Marriages have been brokered
over that.
You show up during the second
cup of coffee, nah, it's a
little iffy.
You're pretty suspicious
to that family.
Third cup arrival of a
stranger means peace.
To drink coffee, to drink three
cups of coffee, not just
slam them down, but to
drink three cups of
coffee, takes time.
And that time is sort of how a
lot of Ethiopia transactions
have been brokered
for centuries.
And I like to think about
Ethiopian that in four miles,
you can have seven different
languages.
And how do you work with
that kind of diversity?
It's sort of a microcosm for
what we're dealing with in the
world right now.
And I like to think that in
Ethiopia, you deal with it by
sitting down and taking
time and drinking
three cups of coffee.
Because if you spend that much
time with other people, you
work through differences.
This is a country that's 60%
Christian and 40% Muslim and
largely harmonious.
It's kind of amazing that
Ethiopia has existed the way
it has with its complexity and
yet been as stable as it has.
I would, of course, like
to tell you that that's
completely because of coffee.
But that might be
an unrealistic
claim to put on there.
Taking the time and settling
down for someone like myself,
when I go to Ethiopia, is always
hard to remember to do,
to be like, I'm going to sit
here and not have a fast cup
of espresso that I can have if
I just go around the corner.
But if I do that, and I get
thicker with it, then where
can I be as a complicated
person?
And that's kind of what
I want to leave this
conversation with.
Because in the beginning, I
asked you all, who's Ethiopian
in the room?
And no one raised their hand.
But I think that if being
Ethiopian can mean embracing
complexity, that we might all
be willing to be Ethiopian.
And if we, as a group, if we can
work with-- if it's just
with coffee that you want to
take out of this conversation,
then go into your local
coffee shops.
Go into your restaurants, and
say, where's this coffee from?
Tell me a story.
But don't just tell
me the good story.
Tell me the big story.
Tell me the good and the bad.
Identify coffee not just with,
well, there's this really nice
coffee farm.
And they don't make quite
a lot of money.
But they really care about it.
And they have really
great children.
I don't want to hear
that story.
I want to hear the stories about
what matters to that
community, what's happening
in that world.
Because we have access to that
through the people who are
working in coffee.
So let's push them
a little harder.
And let's push ourselves a
little harder to tell these
big stories that are
scary that come
from that middle place.
So I'm going to ask
you all again.
We all come from Ethiopia.
It's the cradle of humanity.
But if being Ethiopia means
being our best complex selves
as human beings, being
curious, having full
conversations, who's Ethiopian
in this room?
Right on.
Thanks very much you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
MAJKA BURHARDT: I'm doing a
new project right now in
Mozambique.
And I was laughing with some
of my friends in Mozambique
saying, we're going to be
Ethiopian in Mozambique.
And all my Mozambican friends
were like, what the heck are
you talking about?
I was like, no, because we're
combining and climbing this
2,000 foot granite big wall, so
pretty big objective from a
climbing standpoint, and
bringing scientists up on it
to find new species of ants
and geckos and beetles and
bugs and then starting a
new conservation area.
And it's all on Mozambique's
second highest mountain.
It's sort of insane to put all
those things together.
But it's been really fun.
And it keeps getting richer with
all the layers that we
add into it.
But I've been made fun of quite
a bit by my team in
Mozambique by telling them to
just embrace their inner
Ethiopian for it.
My favorite story of
coffee in Ethiopia?
I think one of my favorite
stories is there's a woman
named Asnakech Thomas.
And she's the only female miller
in Ethiopia, which is
quite a distinction.
And she's worked really hard
to kind of create this
speciality coffee there.
And she'll make sure
that things are
being separated out.
And she's following them all the
way through the process so
she can watch the
unique profiles.
And one of the main reasons
she wants to do this is
because she's lost two sisters
to fistula, basically early
death from child when they
were going through labor.
And maternal health has a long
way to go in Ethiopia.
And there's been a
lot of work done.
And when you talk to Asnakech
and you can
get her to that point.
And you're like, why are
you working so hard?
She's so innovative.
She comes up with all these
brilliant ideas.
She's been a cheese maker.
She made wedding cakes.
She grew castor plants.
And now she's thriving
in coffee.
And she's like, I want coffee to
create a hospital in Amaro
so that people like my sisters
don't come home two in a box.
And two in a box means
mother and child
together in the same box.
Because they died during
childbirth.
And it's not an origin
story of coffee.
But it's the passion and that
she can see that coffee has
the potential to do that in her
home is really amazing.
AUDIENCE: We had an author a
while ago who was talking to
us about the Bordeaux region in
France and like all of the
different things they
do to make their
wines what they are.
And half of that
is technology.
But the other half is just the
practices that they use to
grow and to activate
the vines.
Are there things that these
people could sort of transfer
from that--
MAJKA BURHARDT: From the
winemaking culture?
AUDIENCE: From the winemaking
culture.
I mean, if we're talking a wine
list in a restaurant, and
we're talking now
a coffee list.
Seems like--
MAJKA BURHARDT: There's
quite a bit.
Because it's all about--
AUDIENCE: It's a family
business in Bordeaux.
I mean, it's a very family
business thing.
They're keeping the big players
out, so to speak,
which I think may be important
in Ethiopia if it--
MAJKA BURHARDT: Well,
it's interesting.
Because Ethiopia was
sort of forced--
because of what was happening
in Ethiopia in the '70s and
the '80s from a regime
standpoint, you basically had
the Derg, this Communist,
Marxist bloody regime.
Everything was forced to
not industrialize.
And in fact, that was one of
the tenants of the Derg.
But because of that, it's not
like you're going to Brazil.
And you have coffee being
processed at that level.
It's really small lot
differentiation can still happen.
And right now, it's kind
of a classic evolution.
There's the Jimma research
station that does all this
research on the morphologies
of different coffees and
what's going to make
them thrive.
And when they first started
doing the work, they would
release these [INAUDIBLE].
And they would take a coffee
from central Ethiopia.
And they'd be like,
this is great.
And then they'd shoot it over
to eastern Ethiopia.
And it would just fail
miserably, which now we would
all look at it and be like,
well, of course it failed.
But when they started, they
were thinking, well, we're
making a very drought resistant,
beautiful coffee.
It will always taste the same.
And now it's like, no, no.
We need to make the best Harar
coffees from Harar.
And then, what do you do
to take care of them?
And there's lots of experts
going in, working with the
experts in Ethiopia and
saying, what is
the best soil situation?
What's the best forest canopy?
How do we do this?
And then the question becomes,
if small lot coffee is
actually going to be the wave
of the future, which I would
argue it is.
It's very elitist.
It's very expensive.
But it's the same thing that
happened with wine.
You had super expensive wine.
And then eventually,
it trickled down.
And you have the
differentiation.
And if that's going to happen,
then the hardest thing is that
when I show up with my bag of
cherries from my trees, I have
to watch that bag of
cherries then go
through all the processes.
So that finally we know, when we
taste that beautiful lemon,
where it came from.
And so that's a pretty
big commitment.
But there's a lot of structure
going into place
with that in Ethiopia.
So it's pretty exciting
there right now.
It's complicated to get coffees
out of there sometimes
because of the way export
trade happens.
I'm sure you all at Google run
into, how do you work with
Ethiopia as a company
with its laws?
My first book, that was
published by an Ethiopian
publisher, actually had to be
purchased from a cousin of the
publisher in England to be
shipped out of Ethiopia.
Because they were like, well,
we can't just have a book on
loan out somewhere.
We have to purchase them all.
It's crazy.
So I got into export policies.
And I was a writer.
Who knew?
AUDIENCE: Are there any major
players exporting coffee?
I never really hear.
Maybe you do.
MAJKA BURHARDT: Major players
exporting coffee.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MAJKA BURHARDT: In Ethiopia?
Or which countries?
Or which companies?
AUDIENCE: Out of Ethiopia.
MAJKA BURHARDT: Yeah, so there
are Ethiopian companies.
But usually they're
partnering.
You have the whole range.
You have someone like
Blue Bottle
Coffee in San Francisco.
Those guys are great.
They do a really good job with
small differentiation.
You have Starbucks.
Starbucks has massive power in
Ethiopia, not in like sketchy
power way, but in like legit.
They have made really big
changes in Ethiopia because of
being able to work with such a
big group of people and then
work on some of that.
So most major coffee companies,
be it something
like Starbucks, be it something
like Intelligentsia,
be it a company like Novo
in Denver, they have a
relationship in Ethiopia.
And now the big thing a lot of
people in Ethiopia are trying
to do is actually not just
export green coffee, but
export roasted coffee.
So they have a little bit
more control over it.
The problem is that when you're
exporting roasted
coffee from Ethiopia, it's like
if you're going to roast
it and then drink it in a couple
days, it gets a little
bit murky with how you're going
to do that with large
amounts of it.
I realize I should show you
the photographers' names.
Because they would love it
if everyone knew that the
beautiful images are not mine.
Because I'm lucky.
And I get to work with great
professional photographers.
AUDIENCE: You touched
on politics a
little bit in Ethiopia.
Is the political situation
in Ethiopia such that the
development that you're
talking about
can actually happen?
Or is the politics getting
in the way?
MAJKA BURHARDT: Great
question.
Ethiopia has a goal itself that
it wants to be a middle
income country by 2050 or
something like that.
It's an incredible goal.
It's actually a little bit
insane if you really think
about it, which makes
it really beautiful.
So actually, the Ethiopian
government is-- depending on
which initiatives you're
working with.
Education is one of the things
that they've really set out as
a mandate to go after, which is
one of the reasons Imagine
1 Day chose to work
in Ethiopia.
Because they're like,
we're going in.
The government really wants
to buttress education.
So we're going be able to
work hand in hand there.
So it depends on what
kind of development
you're trying to do.
When you step over into press
freedom, Ethiopia is not-- if
it's like, let's make
more journalists.
That's not really going
to be supported
that well right there.
But the same thing with like
internet access or the way
that texting works
in Ethiopia.
But I think that one of the
things that the Ethiopian
government is really trying to
spearhead is actually wanting
to be that progressive.
If you set a mandate that you
want to be a middle income
country in a very short amount
of time, then you're going to
have to be willing for people
to get in and kind of get
grisly and dirty with how
they're going to do it.
And they've been really
supportive, I think, to a lot
of sustainable development
groups.
Sustainable development is one
of those things that's almost
becoming a phrase that doesn't
mean anything anymore.
And I think that's really
unfortunate.
Because it's a big difference.
Sustainable development
and aid are on other
sides of the spectrum.
And I'd love to see us have that
word not fall away and
become like, nah, whatever.
But actually support that word
and ask people what it means,
what it means to extract
yourself from somewhere, what
it means to have these schools
support themselves because
they have income generating
strategies for schools.
There's this great group I work
with called the Himalayan
Cataract Project.
Horrible name for a group
working all over the world.
But they do eye care.
And when they do eye care in
Ethiopia, they've trained tons
of nurses and local surgeons
to do these cataract
interventions so that they come
in and bolster it and
more numbers happen.
But it's being self-sustained
in Ethiopia.
AUDIENCE: How are you seeing
sustainable development work
out in Ethiopia?
Coffee has a really long
history and tradition,
especially in Brazil, of really
not being sustainable.
So are there organizations?
Or how are people learning to
become sustainable farmers or
build a sustainable
food chain?
MAJKA BURHARDT: When you
bring up Brazil--
it's sort of Ethiopia's
blessing
because of its history.
Because it wasn't
industrialized.
Because it wasn't using massive
amounts of chemicals.
Because everything wasn't
getting poured in the same
place, it kind of has a bit of
a weird advantage to that.
But when we're talking about
sustainability on that level,
there's a lot of work
being done to that.
It's been really difficult
in Ethiopia.
It's probably the same thing
in the Bay Area, right?
You have a really small farm.
They want to get an organic
certification.
The money they have to pay to
get an organic certification
is really prohibitive.
So there have been different
coffee companies that will go
in and be like, we'll
cover this.
Or you guys get your
Rainforest Alliance
certification.
And we'll help you work
through that.
Because the rest of the world
wants to see that stamp and
wants to know that you're going
through those practices.
I would say that a lot of the
coffee grown in Ethiopia
already sort of falls under
sustainable practices.
But it's about actually being
cognizant and focused on
continuing it as things start to
get industrialized and also
as money starts coming
in for coffee.
Because once you get more money,
it's like, let's grow
the coffee faster.
Let's get it going.
It's like, whoa.
Actually, we need to
go the slow way.
Because that's going to
be where that value is
going to come in.
So there's a fair amount of
agricultural support.
It's an agrarian country.
So you have that.
And it's an interesting thing.
Because there's actually a lot
of intervention from China
right now, especially
in the roads and the
telecommunications industry
in Ethiopia.
And then as that starts to bleed
into agriculture, where
those kind of sustainable
mandates, where they hold up
and when they don't.
And I'm really curious to see
where Ethiopia is going to
fall on that in the
next couple years.
AUDIENCE: How does fair trade
play into the economics of
coffee in Ethiopia?
And what do Ethiopians
think of fair trade?
MAJKA BURHARDT: My favorite and
least favorite question.
So fair trade's complicated.
Because fair trade is like
this great idea, right?
And I use it as an example.
When I first went to Ethiopia,
I'm like, fair trade,
organic, let's go.
And then when you get into the
nitty-gritty of it, you
realize that fair trade can
sometimes be a limiter.
Because fair trade
sets a price.
And then sometimes those farmers
can't get more than
that for their coffee.
So it kind of has this back end
limitation involved in it.
So in Ethiopia, fair trade
initially was seen as
something that was
really great.
Because it meant that you got
a little bit more money for
your coffee.
But now it's seen as,
how can we make
fair trade more flexible?
Because that's how fair trade
has to evolve to be most
effective for some
of these products
as opposed to saying--
the fair trade price does
fluctuate depending on what
the commodity price is.
But it doesn't allow for the
price to be like crazy because
all of a sudden people tasted
this one coffee and think that
it should get $95 a pound.
It doesn't accommodate
for that.
So how can we kind of use
fair trade would be my
recommendation and use--
it has such a hold
over people.
It's amazing.
We see it as a stamp.
Like when you buy things,
you're like,
oh, it's fair trade.
It's probably better.
It's been really effective
at its marketing.
And I would say, if fair trade
can keep evolving so we can
use that mind share it has, then
it's going to be the best
circumstance for Ethiopia.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
harmony between the Muslim and
Christian communities
in Ethiopia.
In almost all around the world,
there's some trouble in
between the two.
What's the secret sauce?
MAJKA BURHARDT: I think the
secret sauce in Ethiopia is
that it's just mingled.
I have a good friend named Teddy
Berhanu who I've worked
with on probably seven
different projects in Ethiopia.
And Teddy just tells
it how it is.
This is a guy who at one point
was pulled over by some
militia dude with a
big machine gun.
And he walked out.
And he was so mad that
he went hand-to-hand
combat with this guy.
Got rid of the machine gun.
Tied him up.
Put him in the back
of his car.
Drove him to the nearest
police station.
That's Teddy.
He's just like-- he's
like, [GRUNTS].
But he's kind of this little
really nice guy.
And I always ask him about the
Muslim, Christian thing.
And he's like, Majka,
whatever.
I grew up.
And it was my birthday.
We would have my birthday.
And then it was like,
oh, you're fasting.
But I'm not fasting.
So I'll make sure that your
Muslim father cuts
the meat for you.
And then when I come over, I
make sure that your Christian
neighbor shows up and does
what I need to do.
I think that there's just been
so much integration that it's
worked really well.
On the flip side of it, there
are parts of Ethiopia where
that's not happening.
And there's parts of
Ethiopia where that
tension is being prodded.
And that's really unfortunate.
Because sometimes there are
reasons for tension because of
the way that assets have been
allocated, land's been allocated.
But I actually think that quite
a bit, because of it's
position in the Horn of
Africa, other groups
are going in there.
There's a big insight in from
the Protestants groups trying
to be like, let's
stir the ashes.
Let's feed the fire
a little bit.
And if anything, that's the
thing we should be fighting to
not happen.
Because I think that--
it's like I said.
There's so much diversity in
Ethiopia that it isn't really
about if you're Christian
or if you're Muslim.
It's really about, well,
what else you got?
Because there's a lot more
things that make us different.
And so it becomes less
relevant within that.
And you just have that mapping
and continuous overlapping.
AUDIENCE: Please, give
a hand to Majka.
[APPLAUSE]